E aí galera que assiste meu canal tudo
bom com vocês bom a gente tá começando
agora Um documentário mas vale a pena
lembrar
que não é um documentário sobre Box é um
documentário sobre foco porque como eu
sou quem eu sou No Brasil se eu decidir
pintar um quadro eu decidi que eu quero
fazer agora salto com vara no meio disso
no meio dos treinos eu vou ter que fazer
um monte de coisa porque eu só
requisitado para fazer um monte de coisa
então o que a gente tentou fazer foi não
perder o foco para ir rumo a vitória ao
polonês então a gente trabalhou foi isso
a gente trabalhou muito mental a gente
trabalhou muito
eu sempre digo a gente porque tem a
parte minha que eu me esforço muito
assisto muita coisa até deixar minha
cabeça muito no lugar um deixar minha
cabeça confortável é um lugar
confortável para eu viver dentro dela
entendeu mas tem equipe tem um professor
Eliéser que foi de box tem o Caio que
que faz para preparação física para
poder tá bem para treinar o box Daniel
Coimbra que faz
fez a dieta e toda alimentação para a
gente conseguir bater o peso direitinho
para quem não sabe Box funciona desse
jeito pelo peso não importa a altura da
pessoa você só tem que bater o mesmo
peso que isso é justo se eu sou mais
pesado que você foi lutar com você ou
vai ser injusto porque minha mão vai ser
mais pesada mesmo que você seja mais
rápido seja isso seja Aquilo é uma hora
entra e aí
é caixa então você vai ver desde o
comecinho do Camp a gente chama de camp
quando a gente começa a treinar para uma
uma ocasião específica você vai ver
desde o comecinho você vai ver que eu
começo meio lento começa aí vontade e
tal e você vai ver como eu termino muito
rápido muito ágil e com muita vontade de
vencer isso tudo é uma coisa que você
constrói não dá para você fazer de hoje
para amanhã ah eu tô hoje para baixo ai
hoje eu tô assim tô assado e
quarta-feira que vem você já tá na ativa
não você tem que construir isso com o
tempo é isso que eu mostro nesse
documentário então se você gostar eu já
peço que você como você me conhece já né
numa pessoa desconhecida para você já
deixa o like aí você já sabe qual vai
ser um conteúdo daqueles legal bacana
vocês pede sempre para eu estar fazendo
vídeo para o YouTube e isso é um vídeo
para o YouTube
só é grande
mas é um vídeo para o YouTube também
então deixa o like aí embaixo comenta
embaixo que é que você tá achando qual
parte você acha que eu deveria focar
mais que vai vir mais coisas assim aqui
no canal eu gosto de fazer coisas assim
do tipo faça você mesmo para vocês
entender como é que eu tô fazendo que eu
sei que vocês trabalham aí para
vocês têm vocês olha às vezes para mim
fala assim o cabo desse falando um monte
de besteira falando um monte de coisa
ganhando dinheiro ganhando eu sei que
vocês pensam assim também mas eu quero
entregar para vocês como é que eu faço
para você poder fazer também no seu
trabalho ou naquilo que você quer focar
vamos nessa Assiste aí
Bom dia
a minha voz está mais grave porque hoje
é o primeiro dia de treino
essa carinha Redonda vai sumir
e é isso mesmo ovos
[Música]
Essa é a marquinha do wi-fi
o pé no chão vai
vai
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bom aí a gente teve a nossa primeira
paradinha no sequência de treino aí para
poder fazer uma parada que foi o clipe
com a tília né a gente fez eu fui
convidado né para fazer a música com a
tia Ellus e eu tô eu gosto de fazer eu
gosto de fazer muita coisa ao mesmo
tempo cantar é uma coisa que eu gosto
muito de fazer atire uma pessoa que eu
gosto muito então a gente foi fazer mas
como eu falei tentando não quebrar o
ritmo de treino entendeu então a gente
colocou um treino no meio da parada
legal
[Música]
[Risadas]
porque eu não posso ser sexy
[Música]
o treino entre a gravação é uma parada
que não é fácil de fazer não só pelo por
você cansar cansar é o de menos cansar
todo mundo cansa trabalhando
Às vezes você tá lendo a parada que você
tem que estudar e tem hora que tem que
parar de ler porque você não aguenta
mais tá cansado mentalmente você cansa
para mim a dificuldade mesmo é sair de
uma frequência para outra frequência
porque quando tá atuando quando tá
cantando tá vibrando de uma forma Aí do
nada tu tem que do modo animado e modo
feliz e modo ator modo sério
focado faz faz professor faz
vai faz aí a cabeça do cara tá em outro
lugar não pode para mim essa é a parte
mais difícil né
isso é sexy também
eu tenho uma beleza rústica entendeu Eu
sou uma pessoa que eu sou eu sou como se
eu fosse uma mesa de centro que é só o
tronco entendeu é uma beleza antiga
primitiva não é aquela coisinha bonita
aquela mesa de sentar Ok espelhada
bibelô em cima coisas bonitas chiques
livros entendeu fotos não eu sou um
tronco entendeu e sou também útil né
Felipe você apoiar uma coisa tudo mais
mas tem que ver tem coração aberto tem
que ver a beleza em mim aí você não
acredita que eu posso ser sexy essa foi
a parte mais difícil para mim de todas
as
todas as gravação né
então ele vibrar sexy não sei fazer isso
tá bom
[Música]
[Aplausos]
o o Whindersson curte muita parte
astronomia de espaço e tudo e outro dia
tava lá no Instagram ele mandou uma
pergunta lá do faratu Será que tem como
GP pegar esse kanor aí do Foguete né e
transformar Isso numa energia e tal e
não sei o quê porque realmente a
pergunta faz todo sentido né a criança
pequena lá no Piauí você tinha que ser
bonito lá né com certeza para mim eu do
céu do Piauí é um dos mais bonito que eu
já vi esse
que é muito Limpo o meu tava te falando
antes da gente começar aqui chega um
lugar que você começa a ver uma uma
massa de tanta estrela assim um Rastro
branco é tão bonito
avançar muito foi
eu dizer para mim mesmo quando eu não
sei uma parada eu não sei eu não tenho
resposta para isso você vai colocar uma
câmera e na frente dessa câmera eu vou
ter um sistema de lentes uma lente Ok
então eu tô criando sensor de calibração
em que essa
lente esse conjunto de contribuir no
bojo na lateral do Telescópio sensores
de luz
funcionando sério
tá mais inteligente eu acho que deu
certo
vai levar viu Obrigado Whindersson siga
o Whindersson lá acompanha a luta também
né e acompanha no Netflix de Abril em
Londres
batendo os ricos aí vamos lá acompanhar
Valeu ajudado Estamos juntados também
vamos fazer o telescópio aqui ao vivo ao
vivo show Valeu galera boa noite fomos
[Música]
que tem outro nível
essa pizza
[Música]
aí a gente foi no podcast né sobre
astronomia o podcast eu gosto mesmo um
assunto que me interessa muito no futuro
quero estudar também sobre isso e eu não
tava não tô dando entrevista já faz
muito tempo já né Faz tempo que eu não
tô conversando mas conversar sobre o
tema que não é relacionamento ai
show é sobre uma coisa que eu gosto de
conversar é bom e é bom também para a
gente assimilar o nosso cérebro precisa
de respiro também porque todo dia falar
de box todo dia assiste Box todo dia tem
hora que a gente precisa deixar
descansar que ele vai fazer a sinapse
que tem que fazer cara nem tudo se tem
que achar que você sabe o caminho não às
vezes é só deixar ele quieto e ele faz a
parada enquanto você tá dormindo ele já
e no outro dia a gente já foi para o
Google tentar arranjar parceiros Para
apoiar a gente nessa empreitada que é o
box né E aí o que que a gente conseguiu
nada
o único é o pics back mesmo
essas outras é tudo é minha mesmo isso
aqui é minha você quer minha marca das
Cuecas das roupas
e a Tron que a minha marca de tecnologia
que inclusive foi com o Dário né que é o
meu sócio aqui na Tron que a gente foi
não podcast sobre astronomia né porque a
nossa empresa Tron a gente tá criando
telescópio para as crianças a gente tá
fazendo telescópio que você pode botar
ali onde tá a lua e eles
o índice isso já existe beleza mas a
gente tá fazendo um que é para ser
acessível tá ligado que você possa ter
na sua casa que a criança que está o seu
redor possa ter um contato com
telescópio cedo não como eu que demorei
sei lá quando fui ver um telescó a
primeira vez meus 19 anos a luva também
a gente tá fazendo a luva que pode dizer
qual a força do seu soco que soco foi se
você deu um jepse você deu direto se
você deu um cruzado quantos socos você
deu no round enfim muitas paradas a
gente também já fez um aparelho que tá
em evolução ainda né porque ciência é
isso você não cria uma parada do nada
você vai adicionando coisas vendo erros
consertando
erros
consertar só o erro mesmo dá para
consertar que já tá bom né vai fazendo
direitinho e esse aparelho ele
aproxima a pessoa com deficiência
auditiva das festas da música entendeu
do som mesmo assim tem muita gente no
fragmentos lugares porque eles não têm a
proximidade com o som e a gente
perguntou para várias pessoas com
deficiência auditiva que se eles
conseguiram curtir uma festa e eles
falaram que quando tão perto da caixa de
som eles conseguem sentir a pancada
então o que que a gente fez a gente
aproximou a música do corpo da pessoa
com deficiência auditiva e enfim a gente
já fez várias experiências iradas Espero
que você conheça a Tron aí os Instagram
as paradas estão tudo aparecendo aí na
tela você pode dar uma olhadinha aí
Confira aí como é que foi a gente no
Google para não conseguir nada
valeu a pena tentativa
valeu
[Música]
duvido
como se eu não pudesse fazer a parada
sendo que tá dentro da minha esfera
então sobre Popó né tá aqui para contar
essa história pra gente
ver aqui tem um mas ele já vai logo
querendo desafiar né o tetra
campeão
50 vivências e tudo mais eu vou cantar
até o final do próximo ano se não
funcionar no box e também não funcionar
na música aí no 2025 eu faço um show
falando sobre ter dado ruim no box
dois anos aí na pindaíba e é por isso
que eu tô falando por favor galera
me ajuda
e aí e aí eu faço dessa forma eu gosto
de coisas artesanais por exemplo eu eu o
meu vídeo eu gosto de editar com carinho
assim eu mando as vezes com o editor mas
aí ele me manda eu faço não esse não é o
vídeo que eu gosto de assistir E eu
curto entendeu É como se eu pegasse uma
roupa que tem uma costura de uma forma
tá bom tá costurada Mas eu prefiro outro
tipo de costura então de costura de novo
entendeu então a minha parada é mais ou
menos assim eu gosto de ir juntando um
pedacinho eu acho que faça sentido
alguma coisa com a outra é No outro ano
que eu vou cantar então eu já fiz música
sobre sobre o box
porque eu tenho que contar minha vida eu
já sei o que vai acontecer eu ainda não
tem mas eu já sei que eu vou lutar então
eu já escrevo sobre ter lutado mesmo sem
saber como que vai ser a luta entendeu
Eu gosto de dizer assim camada por
camada
rosnar para os meus adversários vamos lá
sabe do lado direito
esse bucal aí né que é esse negócio de
proteção do dente
aquele negócio que a gente fala né
Respeito é bom e conserva os dente né o
bucal é mais para isso é para a gente
não
quebrar mesmo o dente entendeu ele tem
uma placa por dentro daquela borrachinha
tem uma plaquinha o que eu faço tem uma
plaquinha que é para não para conservar
mesmo o dente e eu quis fazer no formato
de onça porque para essa luta de
inspiração eu comecei a dar uma estudada
assim nos felinos
porque o felino é um animal que ele tem
um
reflexo muito bom entendeu isso é bom
para quem faz Box o reflexo você tem que
ser ágil sua cabeça tem que estar boa
para você isso que vai responder a gente
vê na internet assim que tem uns gatos
por exemplo que às vezes a cobra tá 2 cm
de distância ela tá com o gato sai fora
ainda dá um tapa na cabeça porque diz
assim tá ficando doido entendeu
Eu já vi gato tirando comida de boca de
crocodilo
então a gente deu eu dei uma estudadinha
assim mas nos felinos assim
e em especial eu gosto muito de focar no
felino maior felino Brasileiro né
que a onça pintada
meu corpo eu tenho duas Eu tenho um aqui
meu pescoço e tenho essa daqui também
por que que eu deixo uma olhada nos
felinos porque é bom você tem inspiração
tudo no mundo cansa tudo do mundo cansa
até o que você gosta de fazer cansa Quem
dirá o que tem muito esforço para fazer
então
observar os felinos entender como eles
funciona saber que eles são alongados
entendeu que eles têm essa envergadura e
esse
essa forma ágil porque eles são
alongados tá no Gene dele Lógico que não
tá no meu Gene você é um gato
não sou né mas é legal estudar e é bom
você inspirar em alguma coisa como tem
gente que se inspira em mim para
conseguir alguma coisa na vida não
precisa ser Box não precisa ser comédia
não precisa ser
enfim essa infinidade de coisa mas tem
gente que se inspira é bom você ter
aquilo que te inspira um pouco para você
não perder o fio da meada porque no meio
do caminho a gente cansa velho meio do
caminho a gente fica assim cara que eu
tô fazendo da minha vida meu Deus
acontece
fazer um fisiozinho também que é muito
importante nós não somos de Ferro então
tem várias tem várias profissões que
estão aí para ajudar a gente assim dessa
maneira
que se fala mesmo ajudar porque é um
bônus é uma coisa que que a gente gosta
de instalar a mão gosta de instalar a
perna gosta de fazer massagem a gente
mesmo gosta de comprar aparelho e tal
mas existe a pessoa que estudou o corpo
e que ela sabe melhor do que a gente né
Depois disso a gente foi fazer uma
pública da Oi que eu fui até dormindo
porque o nível de cansaço que eu tava
você não tem noção
eu sou a pessoa que quando eu eu acordo
eu acordo eu não acordei direito não
então fui lá
e é isso
[Música]
Bom dia
tudo bem
porque a mãe falou que para você treinar
3:45 você tinha que comer até meio-dia
para você também não treinar com fome aí
a gente vai aproveitar esse intervalo
para você fazer o figurino a make também
comer para você não ficar com fome
Então quer fazer o figurinha minha amiga
e depois você come antes de
Oi bom dia tudo bem
tudo bem o cabelo tá ficando cada vez
melhor
boa noite
logo após
primeiras gravações a gente vai dar
outro treino né
a gente não é brincadeira mesmo
[Música]
acho que o cara pode treinar doce sim
pode e tal se esforçar fazer mais do que
fazer e tudo mais mas assim
com essa frequência
é nós Só levava um passeio
e ainda tem mais
um cachorro
[Música]
[Aplausos]
quando você luta como se fosse sua luta
mesmo com
um amigo aí de academia e tal é por isso
que eu digo que é bom Por isso que eu
digo que é bom
não interromper os treinos enquanto as
coisas para fazer porque se eu interrom
para os treinos acontecem as coisas para
fazer eu sou espancado no sparring
entendeu e eu não quero ser espancado
por isso que eu treino entre os
compromissos
Isso serve para qualquer coisa você
gosta de ler Ah minha meta é ler não sei
quantos livros até o final de semana até
o fim do ano
ler no banheiro uma frasezinha um
pedacinho vá deixando para depois não
dizer ah eu não consigo fazer Porque
infelizmente é
não sei nem um exemplo para te dar aqui
agora mas o esparrei é muito importante
porque é o teste tudo que você treinou
durante a semana você vai lá e testa
entendeu você treina uma uma nova jogada
ali no futebol final a pelada do final
de semana é aquela pessoa testar se você
aprendeu mesmo uma parada entendeu
Então é isso que a gente faz aí com elas
as redinha que ele bota aqui né
Ah se eles conhecesse o torno
tornozinho daqui para ali
Mas aí tem que ficar nesse negócio aqui
legal legal dá certo também é bom também
é bom é bom
valeu
[Música]
[Aplausos]
os primeiros três minutos é que é
que é difícil e depois
[Música]
sempre
tô preparado também
pessoalmente
[Música]
[Aplausos]
guerra infinita
Sério mano
My Little Pony depois do esparrem
banheira de gelo exatamente com a
banheira de gelo é muito boa porque ela
ela
ajuda a tirar a dor muscular entendeu
existe um monte de coisa que eu não
consigo te especificar agora que
acontece com o corpo quando você faz
muito esforço que acontece com seus
músculos
que são várias camadas de músculos se
você pesquisar no Google Quantos
músculos tem no corpo humano você vai
pensar que tem uns 80 Uns 90 mas tem
mais de 600 tem muito muito músculo
mesmo é músculo por baixo de músculo por
baixo de músculo e entre eles ficam uma
camadas assim de várias coisas que
acontece eu não consigo especificar
Porque é tanta coisa mas entre eles tem
umas camadinhas assim eles liberam muita
coisa
ácido lático
quando você malha ou quando você
treina você não pode tomar relaxante
muscular porque aí você perde o
progresso o que que é o progresso do
músculo é essa micro lesão que ele faz
entendeu Essa micro rasgadinha isso dia
após dia ele vai se rasgando
ele faz microrásio ele vai se curando
dia por dia e ele vai crescendo entendeu
Às vezes você fica com dor de fazer
esforço quando você entra na banheira de
gelo
some tudo até a pomba some Quem dirá dor
se a pomba que é física ela some ela
diminui Quem dirá uma dor que é uma
coisa que é psicológica
[Música]
eu vou gastar tudo com a minha família
outra parte disse que vou guardar para
investir ninguém
acha certo
gente
eu procurei para isso
é maior que Sem estresse
Jack Daniel's
eu não falei para você
[Música]
para jogar água aqui dentro
já existe muita tecnologia também para
poder
melhorar a dor Então mas a banheira de
gelo funciona o gelo é tão acessível né
todo mundo pode ter acesso ao gelo
eu sou piauiense ter acesso ao gelo
mas nós temos acertar o gelo então a
gente pode entrar numa banheira acessar
o gelo e ficar com menos dores mas está
pronto para o próximo treino e logo após
[Música]
aí a gente foi para coletiva de imprensa
né olhar o cara de perto o cara foi no
Brasil e qual que era o foco nesse dia o
foco nesse dia era manter a calma porque
uma das coisas do treinamento que eu tô
estudando e que eu tava estudando na
época era manter calmo mesmo porque o
foco não é aplauso foco não é ganhar no
grito o foco não é o foco é manter a
calma porque mantendo a calma a gente
mantém o batimento respirando direitinho
a gente desce o batimento E aí a gente
não deixa o corpo ser tomado por aquilo
que a gente não quer ser tomado em
momento nenhum que é o nervosismo
a gente não quer ficar nervoso nem numa
situação muito difícil de lidar Quanto é
uma situação muito difícil de lidar a
gente precisa que pelo menos alguém
esteja calmo porque a pessoa que vai
estar calma provavelmente a pessoa que
vai tomar as iniciativas de resolver a
situação eu gosto de ser essa pessoa
então
o foco foi manter a calma
como é que você tá tranquilo
tá bom
[Aplausos]
não encarada monstra hoje já para Embu
das Artes e aí ele chegou no papai e
colocou o narigão no papai papai dele eu
falei ixi
[Música]
[Aplausos]
quem foi que chamou atenção para você
aceitar esse desafio mano com isso mano
Ah cara eu gosto de dar sentido à vida
né Tipo eu eu gosto de fazer comédia eu
gosto de fazer música Eu Gosto de lutar
também e lutar para mim um projeto que
tá dentro da minha esfera entendeu Eu
sou um artista e é um box é chamado todo
mundo como a nova arte né Então faz
parte que tá dentro do meu signo eu não
quero me tornar um Boxeador mas eu
queria passar por um que eu pelo que uma
atleta passa né para se um dia eu
precisar interpretar um atleta no cinema
um Boxeador ou enfim qualquer coisa
assim
[Aplausos]
ah
irmão ai ai ai ai
[Aplausos]
é isso aí né gente o que é isso né Acho
que tem né
[Aplausos]
o último treinos últimos ajustes é aí
que dá para você ver como eu acho como
mudou muito do começo
para os últimos dias
se liga
dia 14 último treino aqui no Brasil a
gente está viajando já já tá ali com o
próprio último treino últimos ajustes
e é isso Partiu para Londres treinar
pegar esse gringo e fazer o trabalho
trabalho bem feito
[Música]
na outra encarada lá
vou botar o nariz de palhaço
tá bom
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ve
pouco a pouco
em Londres
chegamos uma semana antes para ir se
adaptando Aproveitei já para
me isolar mesmo assim que é o que eu
pretendo fazer essa segunda luta também
focar mais no
meu consciente mesmo Não digo nem no meu
inconsciente eu digo inconsciente mesmo
assim
é uma semana muito importante que a
semana da concentração é a semana do
você sumiu cara você não me responde eu
tô focado
isolado tranquilo e de boa praticando o
deboísmo
último treino
antes da pesagem aqui em Londres agora
eu não tô de brincadeira não cara tô de
brincadeira
vamos nessa então
como é que paga as passagens dos caras
os negócio aí
como é que foi o Danilo comprar uma
Kombi
como é que o Caio coisa vai vai treinar
o pessoal na Hugo mano no Brasil tá
ficando cada vez mais caro você quem
você é
você tá ligado o homem foi lá para
contratar o negócio do segurança
não tem patrocinadores
[Música]
último treino antes da luta em Londres
dá para ver como mudou muito desde o
começo estou falando nem de física estou
falando mais de agilidade mesmo assim
felino
no começo ali eu tava assim sem vontade
sem sabe e no final já tô alegre dos
Meus movimentos
tá em rápido do meu cérebro tá
respondendo rápido e aí quando eu tô no
meu Ápice eu tenho que ir de novo na
coletiva para escutar o mesmo blá blá de
sempre então assim eu foco era em me
manter calmo o foco era em me manter
com o cérebro
bem
uma respiração boa porque tudo é
respiração seu cérebro funciona direito
funciona respira direito então me manter
sempre
bem batimento baixo eu foquei muito na
minha respiração para manter o meu
batimento baixo porque o que deixa você
acelerado é seu coração batendo rápido
isso a gente sabe deu um pique correu
daqui até no portão voltou o coração tá
tum tum tum tum tum mas nesse meio do
caminho a gente não lembra de respirar
direitinho de quando chegar na hora do
de descansar na hora do repouso respirar
direitinho para o coração ó
voltar de novo entendeu então procurei
manter isso e levar mais à frente o meu
apelido de iceberg frost free Consul
acesso ao gelo que o gelo está dentro de
mim
mais uma coletiva
vamos lá escutar né
agora
[Música]
[Aplausos]
Cadê o a câmera Danilo
já tá na ativa mesmo
nossa senhora olha isso leão
[Música]
[Aplausos]
muito rápido não consigo pensar né já
foi agora Eita essa mágicas
pronto apesar de hoje
eu tô mais do que pronto eu queria que a
luta fosse hoje que eu
recebe o valor
[Aplausos]
[Música]
pega esse palhaço pega esse palhaço
vai tomar pau do pai nosso
[Música]
[Aplausos]
Esta é a maravilha do testemunhar e
pessoal
que simplesmente foi manter a atenção no
estado de neutralidade
a mente retorna a sua morada natural
como consciência eterna
[Música]
não se apresse em interpretar o momento
apenas a Kate
[Música]
deixa a vida se desenrolar sem
identidade
[Música]
está chegando
velo Mundial
[Música]
[Aplausos]
a gente tá aqui na Irlanda já estamos
aqui faz um tempo mas a gente gravou
tudo para vocês se vocês curtiram esse
vídeo você pode clicar em gostei aí e dá
uma olhada aí
nos próximos episódios que a gente vai
mostrar como tá sendo treinar isolado
aqui na Irlanda tá sendo bem legal hein
espero que vocês curtam vem com a gente
[Aplausos]
[Música]
muita gente quer comprar esses conteúdos
de luta nosso Mas eu prefiro fazer de
graça aqui para vocês no YouTube para
mostrar que vocês estão valorizando
mesmo conteúdo quem assistiu até o
finalzinho até aqui tem uma sequência de
números que eu vou dizer agora eu vou
dizer essa sequência de número Você vai
comentar lá no post que eu divulguei
este vídeo no Instagram o print do
YouTube essa sequência eu vou escolher
alguém para fazer um pics
nada ainda e a sequência é vamos lá
7 3
8 1 9
2275 Essa é a sequência se você chegou
até aqui você assistiu até o finalzinho
e tá sabendo disso vai lá no posto
comenta sequência e bota assim ó e o pix
Beleza eu vou escolher não é sorteio eu
vou escolher sorteio Só quem pode fazer
é a Caixa Econômica Federal eu não tô
nem vendo caixa então se escolher pode
né não pode sortear eu vou escolher
alguém fazer o pix Quanto ah vamos ver
aí né vamos ver como é que vocês estão
de comentário aí tô esperando aguardo o
próximo episódio que a gente gravou todo
o treino aqui na Irlanda tá bom tamo
junto Espero que você curta é para você
por você e também para ele tamo junto